you mentioned in a BBC interview that
you have to be careful how you spend a
lifetime and I'm curious what advice you
would give to another creative person
whether it be a filmmaker actor dancer
who loves the craft of something but is
having trouble transitioning into making
a living from it and they realize that
that may never happen whether it's due
to age or you know talent well they
always ask me that if you had not become
an actor
not anything in films what would you
have done I said much happier position
without any responsibilities at keep
watching films because I still do like
watching moving images I'm talking
moving images I'm not saying human films
now are any moving imagery well it's
National Geographic it's a documentary
when it's harnessed it moves me and I
can I can I cannot walk out even from
the stupid phone because they capture my
imagination I probably try to improve
that silly phone even while it's
unraveling itself in front of me in its
full silly form but I keep repairing it
in my mind so it is an interesting
exercise I think if I had not been in
films I'd still be watching them and so
to somebody who's an artist was trained
but will never perform that is a tragedy
but life is more important I think it is
a tragedy not performed having practiced
so much I only wish that doesn't happen
to too many people because I think there
are people in in my country I'm sure
here too who are not trained
we're not keen they don't want to be in
this but the money is good so they're
here they don't even care if they're not
emotional or coming to do their work and
they get stuff that a trained man
doesn't get that truly
a tragedy it happens but I hope it
doesn't happen too many times I think in
America it doesn't happen too often so
that's why I like the star system in
America because you see it Christopher
Walken suddenly doing a deer hunter and
suddenly and pennies from heaven he does
a dancer number and he said Wow he could
do that and he didn't care about showing
it in the first full I mean I mean who
would have known that as an audience
that Richard Gere could dance or some
other actor could sing so well it's
surprising but I'm happy to see that
stars have always been so very well
trained and now nowadays they're getting
more and more training enviable training
we used to hunger for that kind of
experience for preparing myself as an
actor director all the workshops so and
we believe too many in in in America
you